bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir le bilan d'étape de la COP 28 avec
un grand pédagogue du climat bonsoir
François gemmenons et merci d'être notre
grand témoin ce soir vous êtes memre du
GC vous serez à Dubaï après-demain on
est à mi-parcours de cette grande
réunion diplomatique mondiale avec déjà
quelques acquis mais beaucoup d'espoirs
déçus on fera le bilan d'étapes tous les
deux dans la deuxème partie notre grand
débat ce soir comment relever le niveau
des élèves en France le classement PISA
publié aujourd'hui est alarmant notre
pays dégringole en mathématiques
notamment Gabriel hatal annonce un choc
des savoirs avec des groupes de niveau
et le retour du redoublement estce
suffisant la réponse de mes invités dans
un instant sur ce plateau enfin nos
affranchis ce soir l'international
Isabelle laasserre le bourbon express de
Stéphanie et Pierre et puis
exceptionnellement on partira en direct
du Press Club avec Brigitte boucher qui
nous donnera le gagnant du Prix de
l'Humour en politique 2023 voilà pour le
menu on y va François gémel ça vous
regarde c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite la dégradation ne date pas d'hier
sauf que cette fois-ci la côte d'alerte
est atteinte le le niveau des élèves en
France baisse inexorablement en
mathématique la baisse et même
historique le covid les écrans mais ça
n'explique pas tout alors comment
remonter la pente et est-ce que les
mesures du ministre de l'éducation sont
pertinentes bonsoir Isabelle roche merci
d'être là vous êtes député horizon de
Mosel vous présidez la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
ici à l'Assemblée nationale bonsoir
Annie jeunevard bonsir grand plaisir de
vous retrouver vous êtes députés les
républicains du Doux vous pilotez une
mission parlementaire très attendu hein
sur l'apprentissage de la lecture ici à
l'Assemblée bonsoir Michel desmurger
merci d'être là vous êtes docteur en
eururosciences directeur de recherche à
lINSERM faites les lire au seuil c'est
la suite de votre beststeller sur la
fabrique du crétin digital on va en
parler tout à l'heure dans dans le
détail enfin bonsoir Jean-Rémy Girard
bonsoir bienvenue vous présidez le snalk
syndicat national lycée collège école et
supérieur et je crois que vous êtes
vous-même professeur de de français à
anère tout comme vous an jeunev de
profession et vous aussi François gémen
vous enseignez donc évidemment vous
intervenez un peu plus âgé vous le
souhaitez on va commencer par planter le
décor en quoi le niveau baisse et
comment Gabriel Atal veut-il le faire
remonter le chrono de blackco bien sûr
pour
commencer je me retourne comme chaque
soir pour vous accueillir mon cher
Stéphane blackovski franis gé n'hésitez
pas à faire la même chose bonsir bonsoir
à toutes et tous bonsoir Stéphane alors
c'est le moment de rendre les copies
toujours un peu délicat mais évidemment
avant j'aimerais quand même rappeler un
peu en quoi consiste ce classement PISA
c'est donc une étude internationale qui
est mené depuis l' 2000 sur des élèves
de 15 ans dans 80 pays cette année et
elle est réalisée par l'OCDE qui
regroupe les pays riches et
industrialisé donc voilà j'ai un peu
retardé le moment de donner les notes
mais bon là on y coupera pas hein il
faut y aller faut dire la vérité ne
coupons pas les cheveux en quatre n
allons pas par quatre chemins on est nul
on est nul on est complètement nul
regardez la baisse vertigineuse depuis
la dernière étude de 2018 aussi bien en
math que en lecture alors il y a
effectivement cet effet covid dont vous
parliez tous les pays ont vu leur score
baisser cela dit celui de la France a
baissé de 21 points en Matth alors que
la moyenne des pays de C2 était de 15
points de baisse et de 19 points dans le
domaine de la lecture alors que dans les
pays de l'OCDE la moyenne est de 10
points donc il y a effectivement de quoi
être inquiet en revanche il n'y a pas de
quoi être surpris on le savait on le
savait puisque dès la rentrée l'ducation
nationale avait mené une étude dont les
résultats ont été publiés récemment et
le ministre lui-même trouvait que
c'était inquiétant au niveau du français
et aussi des mathématiques d'ailleurs
c'est sans doute pas un hasard si
Gabriel Atal a publié le jour de du
classement PISA ben les grandes pistes
de sa nouvelle réforme alors moi je dis
réforme il emploie un autre terme lui il
souhaite un électrochoc donc pourquoi
pas je me suis renseigné dans le domaine
de la médecine l'électrochoc est
recommandé pour les dépressions
persistantes donc peut-être que c'est ça
qu'il faut personnel de l'éducation
nationale j'imagine que vous en parlerez
pendant le débat en tout cas le ministre
lui a insisté sur deux idées aujourd'hui
d'abord le redoublement en primaire
c'est quelque chose qu'avait déjà dit le
président lorsqu'il s'est exprimé sur le
sujet il y a 20 % des élèves qui
arrivent au collège sans savoir
correctement lire ou compter alors
est-ce qu'il vudrait pas mieux qu'il
redouble en CM2 la dernière classe de
primaire plutôt que d'arriver
complètement larguer au collège tous les
syndicats d'enseignants ne sont pas pour
ils sont même plutôt contre donc le
ministre a prévu de les impliquer on
l'écoute la question du redoublement
devenu tabou mérite d'être clarifié et
d'être tranché bien aujourd'hui je viens
la clarifier et la trancher avec un
principe simple la décision appartient
aux enseignants c'est pourquoi les
professeurs auront désormais le dernier
mot en matière de redoublement alors
vous avez entendu c'est au professeur de
décider n'empêche si vous demandez son a
ministre ah bah il est très clair et
puis est bien content de vous le donner
en écoute je le dis de manière très
claire il vaut mieux réussir son
primaire en 6 ans que l'échouer en 5 bon
le redoublement ça c'est plutôt pour le
primaire après quand on arrive au
collège là Gabriel Atal a une autre idée
ça s'appelle les groupes de niveau donc
dans les domaines du français et des
mathématiques encore une fois c'est un
sujet sur lesquel les syndicats
enseignants sont plutôt rétissant mais g
lat a dit que dès 2024 ces groupes de
niveau seraient appliqués en 6e et en 5e
on écoute le principe dans chaque
collège du pays les élèves de chaque
classe seront répartis en trois groupes
groupe 1 groupe 2 groupe 3 en fonction
de leur niveau en français et en
mathématiques dans le groupe 1 celui où
les élèves rencontrent le plus de
difficultés nous créerons des postes
pour qu'il n'y ait qu'une quinzaine
d'élèves dans ces groupes des élèves les
plus en difficulté bon ben voilà j'ai
essayé de mettre les grandes lignes du
débat en place alors parfaitement clair
par rapport à depuis quelques années
personne ne nira aujourd'hui que le
niveau baisse maintenant est-ce que vous
serez tous d'accord pour les solutions
ça je sais pas merci beaucoup merci
Stéphane on commence par les maths parce
qu'on a vraiment l'impression que c'est
la bête noire des élèves français ça
fait des années Michel desburgers qu'on
on nous dit ça va pas les maths et là on
perd 21 points c'est la baisse la plus
importante observée par le CDE est-ce
que vous avez des des facteurs
d'explication qu'est-ce qui marche pas
dans l'enseignement des maths selon vous
dans notre pays alors d'abord pour que
les gens comprennent bien ce que c'est
que 20 points c'est un an de
scolarisation c'est-à-dire que les
enfants de 3e aujourd'hui en
mathématique on le niveau des enfants de
4e il y a il y a 4 ans les enfants de 3e
en France sont au niveau des enfants de
fin de primaire c'estàd CM1 CM2 de
Singapour donc en mathématique il y a
vraiment il y a vraiment un problème il
est pas nouveau c'estàd qu'il y a des
études officielles notamment de la de
laad qui montrent que les enfants du
milieu des années il compar c'est des
problèmes de math alors c'est le CM2
cette fois l'effondrement est très net
depuis le milieu des années 87 c'estd
que les élèves très en difficulté 1987
puisqu'ils ont fait ça depuis sont les
élèves moyens aujourd'hui et les élèves
qui sont aujourd'hui lui les élèves les
plus compétents en mathématiques sont
les élèves de milieu de classe de 1987
les élèves il y avait un petit Pol
d'élèves hyper compétent qui a disparu
donc vraiment en mathématique on a un
problème mais on a le même genre de
données en français en lecture et on
venir mais c'est un problème de quoi
d'enseignement de méthode c'est un
problème de recrutement de vocation on
sait très bien que parmi les difficultés
à recruter dans l'enseignement il y a
les profs de mat ou c'est les deux
est-ce qu'il y en a un qui prime sur
l'autre s'il fallait donner des des
facteurs d'explication dire tout un
brique c'estàdire qu'il y a des études
qui montrent que l'usage très précoce
par exemple des des enfants ils ont pris
des enfants à la maternelle et ils les
ont suivis jusqu'en jusqu'en en fin de
de primaire et on s'aperç les mats ça
vient pas de n'importe où la numération
et cetera et et ils sont aperçus que 1
heure de télévision à la maternelle al
ça quand les enfants ont 29 mois ils
sont aperçus que c'était 40 % de
compétences mathématiques en moins quand
ils arrivaient au CM2 alors ça paraît un
peu magique dit comme ça mais ça allit
pas parce que les mats ça se construit
c'est que la numération il faut Serrier
il faut être capable de grouper il faut
être capable d'organiser les choses de
hiérarchiser et quand l'enfant il joue
et qui met les les petits pots dans les
grands et qui met les petits cubes qui
groupe les perles de différentes
couleurs bah tout ça ça contribue à la
pensée mathématique donc déjà il y a ça
il faut que l'enfant soit prêt à
absorber l'enseignement mathématique et
et et ils sont de moins en moins prêt
les Anglo-Saxons on se concept qui je
sais pas comment le traduire qui
s'appelle school readiness c'est-à-dire
que vous pouvez avir les meilleurs
enseignants et la meilleure compétence
il faut que l'enfant soit en capacité
d'absorber voilà et je pense que dans ce
débat on oublie un peu le rôle de la
famille c'estàd que la famille a un rôle
coloss salle et vous pouvez avoir les
meilleurs enseignants les mieux formés
avec la pédagogie la plus tranchante
voilà si les enfants sont pas aptes si
je veux dire si les enfants ils sont
impulsifs qu's ont pas de concentration
que le langage a pas été construit qu'on
n pas lu donc il y a ce problème ensuite
bah il y a sûrement des problèmes de de
de de formation mais ça les enseignants
le diront beaucoup mieux que moi Jean
Girard je viens aux élus juste après
parce que c'est important que d'entendre
les les paroles du du terrain sycapour
c'est systématique inlassablement
premier en ma dans le classement PISA
d'ailleurs après c'est que des pays
asiatiques ils ont mis en place une
méthode on va voir une petite pastille
grâce à nos confrères de de France
télévis pour comprendre qu'est-ce que
c'est cette méthode précisément est-ce
il faut comme le ministre l'a annoncé
aujourd'hui la généraliser en France
regardez bonjour les enfants dans cette
petite école privée les élèves de CP
commencent leur cours de math avec un
problème très
concret mais l'institutrice n'uise son
tableau ni même le manuel les chiffres
sont remplacés par de petits objets
aantés ce que dit l'énoncé c'est que je
vais en avoir trois de plus que
John c'est la phase d'apprentissage dite
concrète celle où les notions
mathématiques font leur apparition comme
si c'était un
jeu les mathématiques c'est abstrait du
coup la façon de rendre concret les
énoncés des problèmes et bien c'est
d'utiliser des objets et des dessins
voilà Jean Gérard on est sur du très
concret de l'objet qui se touche ensuite
on a des images et après seulement on
passe à l'abstraction à la modélisation
et le ministre annonce ce soir qu'elle
sera généralisée vous dites enfin
pourquoi on l'a pas fait avant alors on
dit oui la question par exemple de
concrétiser les quatre opérations au CP
c'est quelque chose qui globalement
marche très bien c'est quelque chose que
nous au snalk on dit depuis assez
longtemps pas de poser une division hein
on va pas poser une une division en CP
avec la potence là mais en revanche
comprendre qu'il y a des partages que
les pares de gâteau et cetera voilà
c'est des choses qu'on peut faire ça dès
le CP et en partant de choses très
concrètes euh maintenant ça
m'intéresserait quand même de savoir
combien ils étaient dans cette classe
dans le reportage il avent pas l'air
très très nombreux et je pense que
beaucoup de professeurs des écoles
Français aimeraient avoir le matériel de
la qualité qu'avait cette professeur de
Singapour parce que beaucoup de nos
collègues sont en train de ramasser tout
ce qu'ils peuvent à droite à gauche de
le fabriquer eux-mêmes et non pas de
fourniture de matériel la priorité c'est
le nombre d'élèves et c'est les
professeurs en face des petites classe
après viendra peut-être la question de
la méthode de
l'enseignementensem les de ensemble mais
la meilleure méthode avec des classes de
30 ultra hétérogène à un moment
elle-même elle va avoir des limites
Annie jeunevard sur les mathématiques on
dégragole quand on regarde le français
c'est pas mieux mo-s 19 points en
compréhension de de l'écrit Gabriel
hatal annonce donc des classes aménagées
en groupe de niveau ça commence en 6e 5e
et puis ça montera en puissance dans les
autres classes du collège avec 15 élèves
maximum pour les plus en difficulté vous
applaudissez alors je pense qu'il faut
traiter le problème de ces collégiens
qui en 4e un collégien sur de ne sait
pas lire convenablement moi je considère
que c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
demandé cette mission d'information sur
l'apprentissage de la lecture je
considère que c'est quelque chose qui
est totalement inacceptable emmener des
élèves au collège qui ne savent pas
maîtriser la lecture c'est c'est
vraiment presque un scandale d'État donc
évidemment on parle beaucoup du collège
mais il faut voir ce qui se passe en
amont à l'école primaire l'apprentissage
de la lecture c'est en CP et en CE1
mieux vaut redoubler si ça n'est pas
àquis alors je pense qu'envoyer un élève
en collège quand on sait qu'il va à
l'échec scolaire quand on le vooue à
l'échec scolaire quand on sait qu'il ne
pourra pas réussir sa scolarité dans le
second degré c'est inacceptable donc là
vous rejoignez le ministre donc là
évidemment il faut trouver des solutions
on verra si c'estes groupes de niveau de
remédiation mais je pense que la
première remédiation c'est de faire en
sorte que l'enfant maîtrise la lecture à
l'âge où il doit la maîtriser et le
travail de monsieur démurget est
passionnant parce que il mon va év on va
faire un point lecture après nous montre
à quel point à quel point ça se joue à
l'école bien sûr dans les méthodes
d'apprentissage mais ça se joue aussi
dans la famille il faut que les parents
enlève les enfants devant de devant les
écrans et les et partage avec eux la
lecture il y a une magnifique
littérature de jeunesse en France c'est
exceptionnel que alors là vous allez un
peu vite parce qu'on est allé à monreuil
on vous montrera il y a un salon du
livre jeesse mais sur les groupes de
niveau parce que c'est un vrai débat et
je vous donne la parole dans un instant
mais est-ce que il faut mettre ensemble
les élèves d'un certain niveau les plus
en difficulté certes dans des petits
groupes mais ça peut-être une é de ne
pas les tirer vers le haut de ne pas
mélanger les niveaux justement oui mais
il faut se mettre à la place d'un d'un
enfant qui est en échec scolaire au
milieu d'un groupe qui ne l'est pas
c'est extrêmement dévalorisant et ça
altère la confiance en soi ces groupes
de niveau ça peut être utile à condition
de pouvoir en sortir faut qu'il y a une
mobilité faut qu'il y ait pour l'enfant
la la la perspective d'en sortir pour
éviter la stigmatisation Isabelle roche
la flexibilité en fait aménager la la
scolarité en fon du niveau quand on a
les moyens aussi de mettre des
professeurs dans des autant faut les
recruter hein dans dans des dans des
classes de 15 vous entendez peut-être je
suis sûr que les syndicats sont pas
forcément d'accord est-ce que comment
vous défendez ça c'est un projet qu'on
porte depuis 10 ans au grouveaui parce
que d'autres de vos c'est un projet
qu'on a conçu en 2013 cette idé de
groupe de niveau en français en
maématique donc en fait les groupes de
niveau comme le ministre les conçoit et
qui les expose effectivement ça répond à
un besoin avec des petits groupes 15 15
élèves et puis une mobilité quand ça va
mieux on en sort et c'est ponctuellement
on va intégrer tel ou tel groupe de
niveau et ça c'est c'est vraiment on
voit qu'on va favoriser la réussite des
élèves par rapport à cela j'entendais
plusieurs choses qui étaient vraiment
très intéressantes monsieur desmurger
disait c'est aussi il faut mettre
l'élève en condition en fait en capacité
d'apprentissage et c'est aussi tout le
sens des des différentes réformes qui
qui ont eu lieu depuis déjà depuis
quelques mois notamment quand on lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire aussi
c'est c'est ça quand on quand on limite
des effectifs à 24 en en CP CE1 voilà
donc on a vraiment déjà on va créer les
conditions de l'apprentissage et en eff
mais avec quel moyen en face parce que
c'est ça le ner de la guerre quand on
voit la
difficulté recrutement les crises de
vocation les speed dating du ministère
pour recruter à la rentrée je j'entends
j'entends cela c'est aussi pour ça que
en parallèle il y a des consultations
pour savoir comment on va rendre plus
attractif le métier on n'est pas les
seuls à avoir cette à être confronté à
ce manque d'attractivité du métier
l'Allemagne le Québec enfin énormément
de pays euh ont ces difficultés de de
recrutement donc à voir comment comment
on fait euh plusieurs pistes sont sont à
l'étude notamment en matière de
formation euh faire euh arrêter
peut-être ce que nous avons fait jusqu'à
présent où on demande à des à des
étudiants en Master 2 euh de d'être
devant une classe de préparer un
concours de préparer enfin c'est c'est
c'est très difficile donc de revoir
aussi comment on entre dans le métier et
puis on en parlait juste
avant d'être d'être à l'antenne quelles
sont les mobilités que l'on peut offrir
aux enseignants à quel moment rentre
dans le métier est-ce qu'on peut en
sortir à un autre moment y revenir tout
ça ça va aussi favoriser quand on dit
mobilité c'est pas uniquement une
mobilité géographique donc ça tout
d'accord avec ça cette approche la
mobilité plus oui il y a quand même un
point qui a pas été abordé c'est le
salaire le salaire oui voilà parce que
on peut toujours toujours dire oh on est
mobile c'est joli et cetera si on est
mal payé à un moment onattrape pas les
mou AC vinaigre et les profs de
mathématiques par exemple on les attrape
effectivement pas avec les salaires
auquel on les REC les revalorisations
ont eu lieu pour les débuts et fin de
carrière où on est au-dessus des moyens
de l'OCDE et c'est vrai que pour tout le
reste on n'y est pas encore le ministre
on est la 7è puissance mondiale la
moyenne de l'OCDE c'est pas l'objectif
he tout à fait mais enfin de là où on
partait il faut aussi voir de là où on
part alors avant de venir à la lecture
je voulais aussi vous soumettre cette
mesure de Gabriel supression du
correctif académique an jeunev j'ai
découvert alors on le savait mais
c'était quand même généralisé hein c'est
un système qui venait relever le niveau
des notes pour atteindre un meilleur
pourcentage de réussite au brevet ou au
bac ça ce sera fini ces réunions de prof
ù on aménage les les notes à la hausse
on triche en fait on triche pour vous
c'est de la triche oui oui ça c'est bien
oui parce que c'est la vérité du
résultat qui importe parce que si on
masque on masque la réalité on ne peut
pas remédier au problème et je je je
crois que il y a là un
impératif de de d'honnêteté par rapport
aux performances des élèves c'est la
raison pour laquelle la question de
l'évaluation est centrale
et les enquêtes PISA le choc auquel le
ministre fait référence ça me fait
penser à l'Allemagne l'Allemagne a connu
cette situation il a quelques années où
ils ont eu des résultats épouvantables
pas bien classé on est mieux que non ils
sont pas bien classés mais ils ont mis
en place ce qu'ils ont appelé le choc
PISA et et et parmi les mesures que le
ministre défens nous nous reconnaissons
beaucoup de de mesures que nous
préconisons d'abord la l'accent doit
être mis sur les savoirs fondamentaux
les le français et les maths aujourd'hui
à l'école primaire vous avez des tas
d'éducation a éducation développement
durable éducation à toutes sortes de
choses alors que pas faire plaisir à
Françis mais je je connais euh monsieur
g je je je pense qu'il faut éduquer les
enfants à ça mais si ça doit prendre du
temps sur les savoirs fondamentaux il
faut un temps dédié pour l'apprentissage
de la lecture l'apprentissage des
mathématiques et au collège nous nous
préconisons depuis longtemps le fait que
le collège unique ne doit pas être le
collège uniforme et ces groupes de
niveau peut-être répondront-ils à cet
impératif jeanré Gérard c'est vrai que
il y a l'histoire des groupes de niveau
et puis il y a aussi l'idée savoir
fondamentaux met le paquet s'il faut
plus d'heur pour les math et le français
et moins d'heur pour les autres
disciplines c'est ça qu'il il esquisse
quelque chose de beaucoup plus souple
beaucoup plus flexible nous les groupes
de niveau à partir du moment où les
élèves en difficultés peuvent être dans
un groupe à effectif vraiment réduit et
là il va falloir des professeurs parce
que moi avec trois classes de 25 je peux
vous faire de groupes de 30 et un groupe
de 15 si mes mathématiques sont bonnes
euh voilà avec trois classes de 30 je
vous fais trois groupes de 30 HE en
revanche j'arrive pas à vous faire à
vous faire mieux donc ça c'est très
important mais ces groupes de niveau ça
peut être une utilité et attention c'est
pas des classes de niveau hein c'est
limité à deux disciplines nous dans
notre projet on avait bien fait
attention à pas créer des classes de
niveau et à bien préciser que l'objectif
était aussi de pouvoir changer de groupe
à la hausse parfois aussi à la baisse on
peut avoir à un moment ça peut aller
moins bien dans sa scolarité et c'est
important qu'on puisse trouver trouver
de la motivation faire des choses
peut-être un peu plus simples et euh et
retrouver le goût de la réussite en donc
mettre l'accent sur les savoirs
fondamentaux ça vous va avec un peu plus
d'heure s'il le faut avec j'ai vu qu'il
y avait une nouvelle épreuve au bac
prère par de math oui on va parler ça
fait au brevet aussi en revanche euh
prendre des heures aux autres
disciplines ponctuellement comme ça moi
je enfin je demande à voir comment ça
s'organise dans un collège lambda moi je
ne vois pas ça ce pointl précis je vois
pas un comment il marche deux je suis
pas certain qu'il soit très sain on va
faire quoi on va supprimer l'art
plastique pour que les élèves fassent du
français ça pose quand même un problème
de l'éducation humaniste on va dire
voilà mais temporairement enfin les les
collègues ont des progressions annuelles
euh si à un moment on dit bon ben on
vous supprime 3 semaines d'anglais pour
que vous fassiez du français du coup
quand vous allez retourner en anglais
vous allez pas être très très en forme
surtout qu'à priori vous êtes déjà en
difficulté donc ce pointl nous on attend
de voir à quoi il ressemble sur sur un
papier dans une salle de classe nous
déjà group de niveau arri à mettre en
place ça c'est déjà beaucoup de travail
ça demande déjà des enseignants et de
recruter des enseignants au lieu de
supprimer des postes ce qu'on a fait
quand même depuis un certain nombre
d'années voilà on on a on a bien compris
que les moyens restent primordiaux
transmission des savoirs vous êtes tous
d'accord priorité la lecture malgré tout
reste difficile on va parler de de votre
livre Ma fremmon elle s'est promené dans
les allées d'un salon qui cartonne le
salon du livre jeunesse et vous allez le
voir évidemment sur place on a des
raisons d'espérer mais quand même quand
on regarde à l'échelle macro c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué
[Musique]
reportage lire c'est la classe et ce
n'est pas Samuel qui dira le contraire
ce qu'il aime par-dessus tout ce sont
les bandes d'essin il y en a beaucoup il
AX Pokémon alors sa maman l'accompagne
dans son goût pour la bulle là il m'a
donné un autre Liv monsieur c'est sur
une petite fille qui
fait oui avant tu me
disais Samuel semble comme happé par
l'histoire en lisant il développerait
ainsi sa concentration et sa créativité
ces bienfaits seraient scientifiquement
prouvés l'une des clés pour développer
son vocabulaire c'est ce qu'on appelle
la lecture partagée avant de se coucher
c'est les histoires al on essaie de se
limiter à une mais généralement c'est
pas plus qu'une on en lit au moins deux
trois en tout cas on ils peuvent pas se
coucher sans histoire vousmême vous
lisez beaucoup oui oui le seul écran qui
est autorisé c'est le vendredi soir donc
le vendredi soir on fait une soirée télé
avec les chips voilà et on regarde les
grands classiques un maximum de partage
et beaucoup moins d'écrans mais quand
ils grandissent c'est en générale une
autre paire de manch alors j'aié le
stylo qui fonctionnait sur ce papier
Nicolas Michel écrit des romans pour les
adolescents depuis plus de 20 ans il
sort aujourd'hui son tout nouveau livre
600 pages sur un thème cher aux
ados j'aime pas trop dire que je parle
d'écologie je préfère parler de de
nature
d'environnement j'ai des enfants de 10
ans qui qui viennent vers un livre comme
ça dit que c'est un petit peu peut-être
un petit peu jeune mais s'ils ont envie
moi j'ai lu des livres très jeunes sans
doute j'ai pas compris la moitié de ce
qu'il avait dedans ça m'a pas empêché de
grandir donc son conseil peu importe le
genre le format le principal est que la
lecture reste un
plaisir voilà alors le secteur du livre
jeunesse est florissant et c'est tant
mieux mais la réalité du pays Michel
durg elle est bien bien différente le
niveau en lecture baisse et ça c'est
bien documenté oui oui le niveau de
lecture baisse il il atteint bah les
études pisal montent mais il y a
d'autres études qui montrent
effectivement qu'on a de moins en moins
d'enfants compétents moins en moins
d'enfants compétents en lecture on a 50
% sur les PISA on a à peu près 50 %
d'enfants qui sont dit de niveau faible
en France sur les études c'est en gros
c'est en gros les 3/4 des enfants dont
les capacités en lecture ce ne dépasse
pas la alors il y en a 50 % qui sont
faibles plus 25 % dans la capacité ne
dépasse pas la compréhension de textees
simple et explicite donc en gros on se
retrouve avec 25 % de lecteurs dont 10 %
de bons lecteurs de lecteurs performants
ce qui correspond au nombre de je sais
pas qui a inventé ce mot au ministère de
la Culture mais de gros lecteurs on a
l'impression que c'est un truc de malade
et pour chasser les gens de la lecture
gros lecteur il y a pas mieux le gros
lecteur c'est 20 livres par an c'est 20
minutes par jour entre 20 et 30 minutes
donc voilà parce que les enquêtes sont
troupeuses les Français ou en tout cas
les les ados disent qu'ils aiment lire
mais ils ne lisent pas pour autant oui
alors il y a une différence il y a plein
de sondages ils aiment lire ils adorent
lire et tout mais il y a une diff ils
aiment lire mais il préfèreent aller
jouer au jeux vidéo et donc voilà il y a
un effondrement du temps passé à lire un
effondrement de la compétence je crois
qu'on ne se rend pas compte à partir il
y a des exemples dans piza on ne se rend
pas compte de la difficulté et du niveau
de la faiblesse du niveau en lecture
d'un grand nombre d'enfants et compr sur
texte simple je sais pas si j'ai 3
secondes pour prendre un exemple dans
PISA il y a des exemples et et voilà et
il y a un exemple c'est la question
c'est il y a trois paragraphes al trois
petits paragraphes la première phrase du
3è paragraphe c'est un problème persiste
et la question c'est la 3oème phrase du
premier paragraphe c'est un problème
persiste quel est ce problème et vous
allez au trème paragraphe il y a un
problème persiste deux points les grands
arbres ont disparu c'est quasiment 50 %
des AL c'est les évaluations 2018 par le
détail des autres mais c'est quasiment
50 % des élèves français qui répondent
pas à cette question on demande aussi
dans un autre exemple combien de temps
la chercheuse est-elle restée sur place
et on c'est marqué dans le deè
paragraphe la chercheuse s'en va après
être restée 9 mois sur place c'est 70 %
des gamins qui répondent pas à cette
question et qui ne qui qui qui sont donc
qui sont capables de répondre à des
textes simples explicites mais les vrais
lecteurs ceux qui prennent l'implicite
d'un texte et la complexité on se
retrouve entre au mieux à 20 25 % mais
les vrais bons lecteurs c'est 10 % donc
oui il y a un effondrement ouais
expliquez-nous en quoi c'est directement
un développement de notre intelligence
de lire la richesse langagière est
beaucoup plus grande c'est une langue
l'écrit par rapport à l'oral oui alors
il y a le il y a il y aigité c'estàd
souvent quand quand on parle de lecture
on fait le raccourci on on assimile la
lecture au décodage qu'on fait au CP et
c'est vrai que c'est une part du
décodage mais si moi je me mets à jouer
au tennis on va me donner une raquette
et ça sera nécessaire mais ça me
permettra pas d'être un joueur et la
lecture c'est pareil c'estàdire que on
va apprendre aux enfants à décoder mais
la lecture c'est une deuxième langue
j'ai une armur thhonis qui disait ma
fille elle est bilingue or l'écrit et il
sa vraiment il il y a beaucoup plus
c'estàd que là je vous vois mon copain
il me dit qu'est-ce que tu es en train
de faire je fais une photo ou une vidéo
il a pas besoin il vous voit il voit les
expressions de visage dans un livre il y
a rien donc il faut mettre plein de mots
et il y a beaucoup plus de richesse
langengagé à l'oral on transmet c'est
des communications c'est des choses
assez concrètes la langue de la pensée
elle est dans les livres et elle est
uniquement dans les livres et euh et et
et donc il y a plus de il y a plus de
mots il y a plus dei ilils ont pris
d'énormes corpus il y a plus de richesse
langagière en terme de lexique en terme
de grammaire la voix passive par exemple
en terme de de temps une richesse des
temps le passé Simp le passé antérieur
je veux dire voilà Gretel poussa la
sorcière ou il lui fallu que tout ça
c'est des temps qui sont que dans la
lecture et ça ne se développe que dans
la lecture et notamment dans la lecture
de livre donc je je sais que c'est pas
drôle à entendre mais soit l'enfant lit
et il accède à ce langage qui est
vraiment le langage de la pensée et de
l'intelligence et plus les enfants
lisent et plus le Tui augmente
littéralement plus ils ont de
connaissance générale donc ce qu'on
appelait avant la culture générale plus
ils ont de créativité pluss ont de
capacité à s'exprimer à l'oral à lire
mais aussi plus ils ont plus ça augmente
leur intelligence émotionnelle ce qui
est un peu la seruie sur le gâteau leur
capacité sociale donc vraiment il y a il
y a il y a un y a il y a toute une
matrice de bénéfice de de la lecture qui
est absolument considérable et et sur la
réussite scolaire le facteur si vous
voulez prédire la réussite scolaire d'un
gosse la lecture c'estes capacités en
lecture parce que on nous a beaucoup
parlé du apprendre à apprendre s'il y a
vraiment une justification du apprendre
ce qui nous permet d'accéder à tous les
savoirs c'est la lecture c'estàd c'est
la lecture qui va permettre aux enfants
et juste une petite étude j'ai fini ils
ont fait une étude dans les pays
nordiques ils sont dit ils ont pris des
gamins de 3è et ils sont dit on va
prendre leur capacité en lecture et ces
gamins ils ont des des différences de
compétences que et en fait 70 % de ces
différences 70 % des différences entre
les gamins s'explique par ou peut on
peut en rendre compte à partir des
capacités en lecture des un gamin qui
sait pas lire et qui a des difficultés
en lecture et c'est pas parce qu'on
gamin il est capable voilà il y a marqué
plus d'exigence à l'école c'est pas
parce que je suis capable de lire ça que
je suis un lecteur il faut quasiment
deux décennies si on prend l'affluence
pardon mais je fais très vite hein
l'affluence c'est la vitesse à laquelle
on lit en ayant compris le texte et et
si on prend l'affluence alors elle a
entre les années 60 et aujourd'hui on
était à 240 mots pour un pour en moyenne
he dans les années 60 on a 190
aujourd'hui donc il y a une baisse qui
est extrêmement nette mais un très bon
lecteur il y a 280 300 mots par minute
et donc si on prend si on prend cette
fluence et qu'on suit les gamins depuis
le CP jusqu'à la terminale on s'aperçoit
qu' il se rapproche de cette fluence là
uniquement en terminal et elle rend
compte du décodage mais elle rend compte
aussi de la compréhension de la vitesse
à laquelle on lit et donc il faut il
faut beaucoup de temps il faut beaucoup
de volume et c'est pour ça g F que on
nous dit les BD c'est bien les mangas
c'est bien mais quand on regarde les
études on s'aperçoit que pour ce qui est
le développement du langage la réussite
scolaire et et et et le développement
des capacités en lecture c'est les
livres ou rien c'est ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas lire de BD et de mangas
ça développe sûrement l'imagination
d'autres choses mais en tout cas pour
ces composantes là c'est une question de
volume il y a beaucoup plus de volume
dans un livre pardon je fais très V vous
tes passionant mais il faut faire un dé
qu je me tais merci alors Isabelle roche
on le voit le con du vocabulaire c'est
très important et je pense
qu'effectivement je par partage en fait
en en grande partie c'est pour ça que
j'écoutéis et que je n'essayais pas de
m'imposer dans dans le déb mais c'est le
rôle de qui avant tout c'est
l'environnement familial on parlait des
lectures partagées de l'école de
l'enseignant de l'institution de l'état
des députés rle c'est le rôle de tous
c'est le rôle de tous bien entendu c'est
le rôle de l'école mais c'est aussi le
rôle de la famille mais la famille il
faut lui en donner les capacités il faut
lui en donner les moyens c'est pas
toujours évident dans le contexte actuel
c'est le rôle aussi des associations le
rôle du périscolaire le rôle de
l'extrascolaire c'est le rôle de de
vraiment de de chacun d'entre nous et et
justement j'écoutis avec attention ce
qui ce que disait mon voisin euh
l'acquisition de du langage et du
vocabulaire est très importante on voit
à l'heure actuelle qu'une grande partie
justement même de de la difficulté de
nos débats c'est tout simplement qu'à
certains moment nous n'avons pas les
mots pour débattre et que si on avait un
langage finalement beaucoup plus fourni
et beaucoup plus nourri ça permet aussi
d'avoir des nuances qui s'expriment
beaucoup mieux que finalement la réalité
du chaos du monde aussi oui mais pas
mais pas que ça c'est met dans des
difficultés à nommer le monde aussi
parfois mais mais c'est pour ça qu'il
nous faut absolument avoir toutes ces
nuances et toutes ces couleurs pour
pouvoir le nommer François gémen vous
vouliez réagir vous qui enseignez vous
avez la chance d'avoir des étudiants qui
réussissent des des concours il y a il y
a un secret il y a quelque chose que que
vous voyez dans cette trajectoire alors
c'est certain qu'évidemment d'abord les
les étudiants que j'ai sont sont plus
âgés euh que je les ai évidemment sur
des matières qui touchent au climat
l'environnement où je peux dire que
d'année en année le niveau monte
contrairement à la plupart des profs qui
se qui se désolle de la baisse du niveau
ce qui me frappe quand même c'est
vraiment la question des salaires moi je
suis très frappé du faible niveau des
salaires des enseignants en France au
collège au lycée et aussi à l'université
un simple point de comparaison une
bourse de thèse en Belgique pour un
étudiant en doctorat en première année
c'est plus que le salaire d'entrée d'un
maître de conférence en France France et
donc j'ai envie de dire si on reconnaît
que ces métiers sont des métiers
essentiels il faut qu'ils aient un
niveau de salaire qui est avec ça et on
voit en tête de classement PISA on voit
Singapour la Corée du Sud le Luxembourg
il y a pas de secret c'est les pays où
les profs sont les mieux payés ou et nos
cerveaux et on en a beaucoup en Scien
comme en littérature vont à l'étranger
qu'est-ce qu'on fait contre ça vous vous
attendez des rémunérations
supplémentaires oui alors on sait on est
un syndicat donc effectivement on a des
on porte des positions syndicales et je
crois C qu' aujourd'hui c'est déjà ça
tout le monde reconnaît que les
enseignants sont mal payés il y a 10 ans
nous on disait ça au SNAL on nous
regardait on se enfin les gens les gens
se marrai voilà ouis les vacances la
sécurité de l'emploi les fonctionnaires
et cetera aujourd'hui ça y est c'est
quand même reconnu que voilà le métier
d'enseignant c'est pas un métier
attractif et toutes les idées et
propositions du ministre il y en a
beaucoup qui sont très bien et on n pas
parlé de la classe pour préparer au
lycée si jamais on n pas eu le brevet ça
nous on trouve que c'est une super idée
ça pour le coup bien mieux qu'un
redoublement d'
le brevet indispensable voilà le brevet
indispensable si vous ne l'avez pas vous
avez une classe de prépcée avant
d'entrer en seconde ça c'est mieux que
le redoublement ça quiment unanimité ce
Gabriel manifestement ce point enfin ce
pointl il est vraiment très très
intéressant c'est des ce qu'on appelle
les propédotiques en éducation c'est des
choses que nous on soutient depuis très
longtemps et qui et ça ça fonctionne
très bien mais il faut des enfin voilà
il va falloir il faut les personnels il
faut les fonctionnaires qui vont avec on
va dire là on on est à 8 % de
contractuel 10 % de contractuel dans
l'académie crû il y a un prof sur 10
dans l'Académie de créille qui n'a pas
le concours nous on voudrait que les
contractuels ils aient envie de passer
le concours et pourtant le budget de
l'éducation est est en hausse plus 6 %
mais ça ne suffit pas ça c'est
l'inflation je voudrais vous demander ça
n'a pas rattrapé l'inflation vous aurez
le mot de la fin ni jeun va vous
préparer une mission attendue mission
parlementaire sur l'apprentissage de la
lecture de toutes les auditions de de
vos débats vous avez entendu Michel
desmurger qu'est-ce que vous allez
proposer alors je peux pas vous dévoiler
totalement les conclusions parce
qu'elles sont réservées déjà à mes
collègues de la commission une ou deux
mesures fortes peut-être mais mais alors
l'idée de la restauration du manuel
scolaire par exemple à l'école primaire
est une idée que nous portons dont nous
avons discuté avec le ministre sa
labellisation c'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut
pas mettre entre les mains d'un enfant
n'importe quel manuel il faut que la
méthode qui est développée soit éprouvée
aujourd'hui il y a un consensus
scientifique sur les méthodes qui
marchent pour décoder comme le disait
monsieur desmurger et puis il faut
encourager la pratique de la lecture il
y a des enfants et là la responsabilité
de la famille est immense de toutes les
familles il y a des enfants qui arrivent
à l'école maternelle je parle bien de
l'école maternelle donc dès 3 ans
certains possèdent 400 mots d'autres en
possède 2000 donc la la l'inégalité est
déjà là au début du du cursus scolaire
donc l'acquisition du vocabulaire il
faut parler aux enfants il faut lire aux
enfants il faut lire avec les enfants et
puis il y a la question de la formation
des enseignants ça rejoint ce que disent
les uns et les autres sur la le le le
professeur est la clé de voûte du
système c'est celui l'effet maître ça
n'est pas un 20 mot euh et donc pour
cela il faut le former à des méthodes
qui soient éprouvées il faut qu'il
puisse travailler avec ses pères euh il
faut qu'il a le dernier mot puisque
c'est il faut il faut qu'il faut qu'il
le
derni le ministre très important c
d'ailleurs c'est une proposition parmi
les propositions que nous avons faites
aux républicains c'est une des
propositions que nous portons la
question du devenir de l'élève dans la
classe supérieure appartient à
l'enseignant mais encore faut-il qu'il
soit parfaitement formé et ce que disait
monsieur Gérard est très important sur
la formation des enseignants aujourd'hui
faute d'enseignants on recrute des
contractuels dont on n'est pas assuré
qu'il possède le niveau requis pour
enseigner là en tout cas c'est
intéressant de voir qu'entre majorité
opposition sur un sujet aussi essentiel
que l'éducation il y a des passerelles
des consensus on s'écoute et de matière
à construire quelque chose on s'arrête
là malheureusement merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu débattre je recommande
faites les lire ça n'est pas une
injonction c'est plutôt une invitation
mais c'est passionnant comment la
lecture stimule l'intelligence de nos
enfants signé Michel des burgés c'est à
lire au seuil vous restez avec moi
François gémen dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties Pr de noous
affranchis ce soir brigette boucher va
nous révéler en direct depuis le Press
Club de Paris le prix de l'humour
politique dont LCP est partenaire et
puis en plateau Isabelle laass du Figaro
reviendra sur la pression internationale
qui s'accentue sur Israël pour obtenir
l'arrêt des combats enfin Stéphanie
Despierre de quoi nous parlez-vous ce
soir dans Bourbon express de la colère
de la France insoumise qui sofusque que
l'État ne protège pas assez ces
parlementaires on verra ça mesdames à
tout à l'heure mais d'abord on va
adresser un bilan d'étable vous serez
demain soir à Dubaï François gémen
certains espèrent d'autres se
désespèrent déjà alors qu'est-ce qui est
à qui qu'est-ce qui ne l'est pas on voit
ça dans l'invitation de Marion Becker et
on en parle ensemble juste
après si on vous invite François gémen
c'est pour nous décrypter cette COP 28
vers laquelle vous vous envolez bientôt
ses enjeux ses ambitions le rôle de la
France dans l'action climatique
co-auteur de son 6e rapport vous êtes
l'un des visages les plus célèbres du GC
politologue chercheur spécialistes des
migrations
environnementales cette COP 28 à Dubaï
au pays de l'ornoir dans une ville
polluée connue pour ses extravagances
climatiques a été décrié et a suscité
des polémiques pourtant dès son
ouverture un accord surprise a été
trouvé sur l'indemnisation des pays du
Sud c'est vraiment la pierre angulaire
de ce qu'on appelle la justice
climatique qui permet que les pays
industrialisés reconnaissent leur
responsabilités dans les impacts du
changement climatique que subissent les
pays du Sud l'un des défis majeurs de
cette COP François gémen c'est la sortie
progressive des énergies fossiles
charbon gaz pétrole c'est en tout cas ce
que laisse espérer le premier brouillon
public servant de base aux négociations
de cette conférence pour le climat son
président l'émirati sultan aljberer
espère que cette édition marquera
l'histoire au même titre que la COP 21
de Paris Emmanuel Macron a annoncé la
fin du charbon en France en 2027 et
proposer un calendrier au monde entier
les pays du G7 doivent montrer l'exemple
et s'engager à mettre fin au charbon
chez eux avant les autres c'est-à-dire
avant 2030 la France tiendra son
engagement de sortir complètement et de
fermer toutes ses ses centrales d'ici à
2027 c'est-à-dire sous le mandat qui est
le mien je ne promets pas pour la suite
l'Inde a déjà opposé une fin de non
recevoir alors François gémen on a une
question pour vous a-t-on une chance le
12 décembre d'acter une sortie d'au
moins une des énergies
fossiles réponse d' moins une ça va être
compliqué ça va être compliqué à mon
avis de dissocier les énergies fossiles
pourquoi parce que en fait le charbon
c'est l'énergie des pays émergents c'est
l'énergie de l'Inde c'est l'énergie de
la Chine et donc pour la Chine ou pour
l'Inde c'est insupportable d'entendre la
France dire on va sortir du charbon
Emmanuel Macron vous avez fermé vos
mines de charbon en France dans les
années 80 et donc c'est facile pour les
pays industrialisés de dire on va sortir
du charbon par contre là des la Chine
qui dépendent moins du pétrole et du gaz
disent au pay industrialisés
engagez-vous sur le pétrole et sur le
gaz qui est considéré comme énergie des
pay indust et les pétromonarchies sont
prudentes les pétromonarchies sont
prudentes évidemment essaie d'être r
donc aucun accord donc j'ai envie de
dire ça risque d'être tout ou rien mais
distinguer les énergies fossiles à mon
avis ça va être compli ça sera rien
objectivement pas sûr ah bon pas sûr pas
sûr aujourd'hui il faut bien connaître
qu'il y a dans les pays industrialisés
il y a pas vraiment d'intérêt à la
sortie des énergie fossile et beaucoup
de pays industrialisés sont très
hypocrites le Royaume-Uni le Canada les
États-Unis qui accordent sans C de
nouveau forage pétrolier ou gazier et
puis ils vont faire de beaux discours à
la tribune en disant il faut sortir des
énergies Foss pays du Sud leur disent
d'ailleurs à dub P Sud leur disent et
ces pays seront très heureux si jamais
ça n'est pas dans le texte de faire
porter le chapeau à Dubaï et aux Imir et
comme les grands méchants mais je seraai
qu'à moitié surpris que potentiellement
dans cette COP où il y a une vraie
énergie positive depuis le début on
parviennent quand même à avancer sur ce
sujet des énergies fossile je serais
sincèrement très surpris et très déçu
s'il y avait pas un pas en avant sur les
énergies Foss d'accord on sent que vous
êtes optimiste on pourrait peut-être se
consoler sur les énergies renouvelables
118 pays s'engagent pour investir
massivement en les multipliant par TR et
pourtant la Chine la Russie l'Iran ne
signe pas là encore vous voyez le le ver
à moitié plein c'est c'est assez curieux
parce que la Chine investit massivement
dans l'énergie solaire donc en réalité
elle remplit déjà l'objectif j'ai
l'impression que c'est une sorte un peu
de rebutade politique c'est très bien
d'augmenter la capacité des
renouvelables c'est très bien d'investir
dans le nucléaire le problème c'est
qu'il faut aussi sortir des fossiles ce
qu'on a vu depuis 20 ou 30 ans c'est
qu'effectivement les énergies
décarbonées se sont développé elles sont
devenues moins chè plus productifes mais
elles se sont ajouté aux énergies
fossiles elles ne les ont pas remplacé
alors il y a une chose que les
téléspectateurs et moi-même aimerais
comprendre les accords internationaux de
ces COP même s'ils sont pas signés par
tous les pays est-ce qu'ils engagent les
parties prenantes et comment est-ce que
si on signe sur les moyens sur un
calendrier on est contre un ou pas en
principe oui mais de facto il y a pas de
sanction donc en fait c'est pas vraiment
mais alors à quoi ça sert tous ces
accords ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que tous ces accords en réalité
c'est des signaux qui sont envoyés au
marché aux investisseurs à l'industrie
c'est à ça que ça sert c'est pas parce
qu'il y a un accord sur la sortie que
malheureusement les états vont du jour
au lendemain décider de sortir F donc
c'est une pression sur la finance pour
qu'elle se convertisse dans les
investisement financiers c'estàdire que
si on dit à un moment donné si un
calendrier de sortie des fossiles les
investisseurs se disent c'est plus
là-bas qu'on va mettre le B et donc le
vrai marqueur du succès d'une COP
d'accord c'est de voir l'évolution du
cours de l'action total énergie Shelle
ou BP le lendemain si le cours a baissé
c'est que la COP est réussie si le cours
a monté c'est que c'est un échec si le
cour n'a pas bougé c'est que les cops ne
servent à rien on peut se féliciter du
fond perte et dommages ça c'est c'est
fait les pays riches vont payer les
dégâts du réchauffement climatique des
pays pauvres comment euh l'argent
va-t-il être distribué 650 millions de
dollars débloqués est-on sûr qu'il va
aller au bon endroit pour le moment
alors justement c'est pour ça qu'on a
mis en place avant un organe de gestion
de ce fond qui va être hébergé pendant 4
ans par la Banque mondiale et qui va
garantir que l'argent aille à ceux qui
subissent les dégâts les plus lourds
donc il y a un mécanisme de gestion qui
est en place pour ce fond et ce fond
même si nous en France on est peu
concerné parce qu'évidemment on va pas
toucher d'argent c'est très important
c'est vraiment pour les pays du Sud la
reconnaissance d'un début de justice
climatique c'est le préalable à toute
discussion avec les pays du Sud CELI
dont tout le monde parle c'est sultane
Ahed aljabert qu'on va voir à l'image le
président de la COP et ministre de la
compagnie pétrolière émirati il enchaîne
les polémiques depuis l'ouverture de la
COP il y a évidemment sa double C quête
mais il y a aussi les accusations
récemment il a été accusé d'avoir
minimisé les termes même écrits dans les
documents de négociation préférant le
mot de réduction au mot de sortie des
fossiles ça fait quand même une très
grosse différence et c'est sur là-dessus
que tout va se jouer dans le texte final
à quoi jouteil est-il digne de confiance
c'est un c'est un diplomate qui donc va
essayer de jouer sur différents tableaux
va parfois envoyer différents messages
et différents signaux selon ses
interlocuteurs je crois qu'on a tendance
parfois à le réduire un peu à son
étiquette de PDG une compagnie
pétrolière et à oubli ses qualités
l'habileté de diplomate qu'il a par
exemple annoncer l'accord sur les peres
des dommages dès le premier jour de la
COP c'est un coup de Mare c'est très
habile diplomatiquement parce que quoi
ça oblige tout le monde à à se
positionner plus fort pour la suite ça
oblige et surtout ça installe un climat
de confiance et de dialogue entre les
pays du Sud et pays industrialisés
jusqu'ici les pays du Sud avit
l'impression d'être roulé dans la farine
avait l'impression d'être mené en bateau
cet accord c'est le signe qu'on ENIT au
P du C en disant on vous prend au
sérieux les 1,5 degrés de réchauffement
de la planète on y est enfin je veux
dire on y arrivera pas au d'cord de
Paris donc ça c'est c'est terminé mais
c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut abandonner
l'objectif il faut comprendre que cet
objectif de 1 et demi 1 degr et demi de
réchauffement c'est un objectif
politique c'est un marqueur d'ambition
c'est comme quand vous dites avec une
politique de sécurité routière
l'objectif c'est Z mais quand un
objectif est dépassé pourquoi on
l'utilise encore parce que ça marque
votre ambition parce que vous le gardez
comme une sorte de boussole qui vous dit
c'est c'est là qu'il faut tendre et
clairement même si on dépasse 1,5 le
seuil d'après c'est pas 2 c'est 1,6
chaque diè de degré d'évation va faire
une énorme différence donc il faut
garder ces objectif comme une boussole
politique alors vous qui êtes un
spécialiste des migration climatique on
vous a préparé une carte elle est pas
forcément parfaite qui vous montre d'une
certaine façon à quoi on peut s'attendre
dans les décennies qui vient on a montré
à la à la fois les zones de
désertification et les zones de
migration environnementale on voit bien
que là encore c'est largement le sud qui
est victime avec beaucoup de migration
vers le nord que ce soit l'Amérique que
ce soit l'Europe que ce soit l'Asie
attention à l'orthographe dans grand
Delta exposé nos interlocuteurs du débat
avant vont pas être contents ah oui vous
avez raison bon alors à quoi peut-on
s'attendre dans la décenie qui vient
très clairement on a déjà aujourd'hui le
changement climatique qui est un des
principaux facteurs de migration et de
déplacement à travers le monde en 2022
il y a 32 millions de déplacements liés
à des catastrophes climatiques des
ouragans des inondations des S c'est
davantage que le nombre de déplacements
lié à des conflits ou à des violences à
l'avenir non seulement il va avoir
davantage de migration mais surtout les
caractéristiques desmigration vont être
différentes c'est-à-dire qu'on va avoir
de plus en plus de départs forcés de
gens qui pouront pas choisir le moment
où ils partent l'endroit où ils vont et
donc il y a un vrai besoin dès à présent
d'accompagner ces migrations et de pas
considérer que c'est un risque futur
mais que c'est bien une réalité présent
à l'URE de ce texte de loi qui fait
tellement couler d'encre sur très
clairement il y a un décalage total
entre les politiques nationales d'asile
et immigration et la manière dont ce
sujet est débattu à l'international qui
sait en France qu'il existe une
organisation internationale à Genève la
plateforme sur les déplacements liés aux
catastrophes qui s'occupe de ces
déplacements et qui est pilotés en ce
moment par l'Union européenne tout le
monde l'ignore h alors je voudrais vous
interroger pour terminer cet entretien
sur une image on va regarder une belle
chaîne de montagne celle des Pyrénées
Atlantiques on a appris aujourd'hui
grâce à nos confrères du Parisien qu'un
permis d'exploration a été accordé je
sais pas si vous avez vu cette cette
info pour extraire de ce qu'on appelle
l'hydrogène blanc énergie naturelle sur
laquelle compte profiter l'état énergie
moins polluante alors que d'autres sont
fabriqués en matière d'hydrogène
artificiellement est-ce que c'est une
obè pour nous et est-ce qu'il faut
prendre le risque de forêt dans nos
montagnes en tout cas ça mérite d'être
exploré il faut voir évidemment la façon
dont on le fait malheureusement on sait
que l'extraction généralement produit
des dégâts environnementaux conséquents
mais il va falloir explorer la voix de
l'hydrogène très clairement aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas la capacité ni le luxe
de pouvoir faire la fine bouche par
rapport à des solutions possibles il va
falloir mettre tous les fer au feu donc
les technosolutionnistes n'ont pas
forcément tort on va avoir besoin de
technologie la question c'est la
technologie ne doit pas remplacer un
changement de mode de vie des politiques
publiques ambitieuses une politique
fiscale ambitieuse mais on pourra pas
non plus se passer de technologie bien
entendu merci François gémen vous
reviendrait tiais vouslez de Dubaï parce
qu'on aimerait avoir votre analyse ver
on verra si si la deuxè semaine est
aussi prolifique que la prre en tout cas
c'est tellement plus clair quand vous
parlez climat merci à vous c'est l'heure
des affranchis et de leur parti prix ils
vont vous faire réagir on les accueille
tout de suite Isabelle laasser des pages
diplomatiques du Figaro installez-vous
et bien sûr Stéphanie des pierres on
commence avec vous Stéphanie Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
vous nous racontez quoi l'histoire d'une
histoire pas banale celle de la colère
de la France insoumise qui accuse l'état
de ne pas protéger de ses députés
contrairement à la journaliste de LCI
rel cririf placé sous protection
judiciaire vous le savez après un tweet
très virulent de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
l'accusant à d'islamophobie et bien
Mathilde Panau a remis le couvert dans
un autre tweet et en conférence de
presse ce matin la chef des députés
insoumis s'offusque carrément de la
célérité avec laquelle la protection de
la journaliste a été activée et elle
déplore que ce ne soit pas le cas pour
ces députés j'ai plus d'une dizaine de
députés de mon groupe qui sont menacés
de mort régulièrement j'ai un député de
mon groupe qui a dû déménager à trois
reprises du fait des menaces de
l'extrême droite et je vous assure que
jamais il n'a été proposé jamais il n'a
été proposé à aucun des députés une
protection et parmi les 10 députés
insoumis à menacer il y a Thomas porte
on l'écoute en juillet dernier suite à
un courrier que j'ai reçu d'un comité
qui s'appelle le comité 732 qui est un
groupuscule d'extrême droite qui est un
groupeul connu qui avait déjà menacé
d'autres députés qui m'a fait un
courrier à l'assemblée qui explique
qu'il va me suivre à mon domicile qu'il
va être éud mes parcours qui explique
les méthodes pour me tuer m'enlever me
faire souffrir et à partir de là j'ai
décidé de déposer les plaines parce que
c'était pas la première menace de mort
que je qui é qui m'était destiné donc
j'ai déposé plinte et j'ai demandé une
protection policière notamment devant
mon domicile et devant ma permanence je
n'ai pas de nouvelle de la demande de
protection policière que j'ai fait parce
que à minima si j'ai bien compris la
procédure il y a au moins une analyse
avec la personne concernée c'est-à-dire
moi et aujourd'hui j'ai eu aucun coup de
fil du ministre ou de ses services alors
comment réagit le ministre de
l'Intérieur et bien il explique que la
menace est prise au sérieux quel que
soit le bord poli politique il l'a
expliqué cet après-midi lors des
questions au gouvernement en prenant un
exemple chez les
insoumis monsieur Boyard par exemple a
pu être protégé par la police et c'est
l'honneur de la police que de le
protéger monsieur Bardella a pu être
protégé par la police c'est l'honneur de
la police de la protéger monsieur Zemour
est actuellement protégé par la police
et c'est normal et ce sera le cas pour
toute personne quel que soi ces opinions
qui sera menacé ce sera l'honneur de la
police de les protéger compris dirigeant
de la France insoumise alors pour Louis
Boyard en fait la police faisait des
rondes autour de son domicile pendant le
débat sur les retraites le ministère
nous précise également que les
évaluations nécessaires sont diligentées
à chaque fois que les élus reçoivent des
menaces et que cela a été le cas
récemment pour d'autres députés insoumis
par exemple pour Emeric Caron en octobre
dernier mais plus généralement dans le
camp présidentiel les accusation de
Mathilde Panau ont fait
bondir les insoumis cessent de mettre de
l'huile sur le feu le climat de tension
les menaces exacerbées qui se
multiplient contre les élus contre les
journalistes c'est aussi leur
responsabilité et lorsque Jean-Luc
Mélanchon fait le choix de jeter en
pature la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale il a quelques semaines de cela
dans le cadre du conflit
israelllo-palestinien lorsqu'il s'en
prend de manière explicite à routel
criev dans les termes les plus
ignominieux flirtant avec
l'antisémitisme encourageant les
violences il porte une part de
responsabilité dans dans le climat de
tension tensions qui sont à chaque jour
un peu plus VI et inquiétante François
gémen LFI pompier pierreoman ou demande
légitime de
protection je connais pas le cas de lesf
en particulier mais moi je suis en tout
cas en tant que citoyen en tant que
chercheur complètement atterré du climat
de violence à l'Assemblée nationale
parmi les parlementaires il faut
rappeler que la démocratie c'est quand
même la recherche du consensus la
recherche je dirais d'un choix d'intérêt
collectif à partir de préféren
individuelles comment pourrions-nous
nous étonné du regain de violence dans
la société et de ces gens qui se font
tuer à l'arbre branche ces adolescents
si onz le spectacle qui est offert par
les député est celui d'une d'une sorte
de violence totale dans les paroles o on
arrive finalement à devoir faire
protéger chaque député par deux
policiers c'est infernal et pour moi ça
explique aussi largement ce regain de
violence qu'on constate dans la société
aujourd'hui h merci pour cette réaction
alors on enchaîne avec vous Isabelle
vous vouliz revenir sur la situation à
Gaza où les
sintensifi dans le sud de l'enclave
palestinienne les alliés d'Israël haent
Leon oui alors c'est d'abord le cas des
États-Unis puisque le d'abord le
secrétaire à la Défense lustine et la
viceprésidente Cala Harry sont émis de
sérieuses réseres sur la manière dont
Israël mène la guerre contre le Hamas à
Gaza il y a aussi Anthony blinken qui a
essayé qui a suggéré à Benjamin
netaniaahou de modifier sa stratégie
c'est aussi le cas du côté français où
le président en fait a demandé à Israël
de préciser ses buts de guerre pour
Emmanuel Macron éradiquer le Hamas ça
prendra 10 ans mieux vaudrait un cesser
le feu et poursuivre le convbat contre
le Hamas par des actions ciblées alors
comment vous les expliquz ces critiques
de plus en plus fortes alors en fait à
Washington comme à Paris on considère
que la la manière dont Israël mène sa
guerre est contre-productive elle
enflamme le monde arabe elle éloigne une
solution politique elle met les alliés
des
Occidentaux en difficulté comme par
exemple l'Arabie Saoudite qui est obligé
de faire le grand écart entre son
alliance avec les États-Unis enfin
alliance son sa sa collaboration avec
les États-Unis et sa population qui
gronde et enfin elle gonfle le Hamas en
6isjordanie mais les alliés d'Israël ont
aussi en fait des raisons de politique
intérieure aux États-Unis Joe Biden est
coincé par sa jeunesse W qui est en fait
en empathie avec la cause palestinienne
il est aussi contesté par l'aile gauche
du parti Démocr et par tous ceux au sein
de son administration qui considèrent
que les États-Unis doivent lâcher le
Moyen-Orient et l'Europe pour se pour se
focalisé sur la Chine et côté français
Emmanuel Macron redoute une importation
du conflit sur le sol national alors
est-ce que toutes ces critiques ces
pressions peuvent avoir une influence
sur benamin netan non pas pour l'instant
pas pour l'instant puisque de toute
façon il n'est pas question pour les
États-Unis de limiter enfin d'arrêter
leur aide militaire à Israël netanahou
avait accepter le principe d'une trêve
humanitaire mais c'est plutôt l'opinion
publique israélienne qui lui avait qui
avait exigé qu'il fasse passer la
libération des otages comme priorité
numéro 1 pour le reste les objectifs
restent les mêmes se débarrasser du
Hamas quoi qu'il en coûte et ça prendra
du temps il a aussi sans doute une autre
raison c'est que les objectifs de
netaniaahou se débarrasser du Hamas sont
suivis par l'intégralité de la
population mais la grogne monte contre
le Premier ministre tant qu'il est au
pouvoir tant que la guerre continue il
reste au pouvoir après ça risque d'être
une autre histoire ouai chacun est tenu
par sa scène intérieure merci infiniment
d'un tout petit mot c'est la fuite en
avant pour vous cette guerre d'Israël
contre le Hamas il y a quel et c'est
aussi je pense une sorte de fuite en
avant pour Benjamin netaniaou je pense
que c'est utile de rappeler que c'est
quand même le Premier ministre le plus
corrompu de l'histoire d'Israël et que
quelque part il y a quelque chose
d'assez tragique à se dire qu'au moment
où Israël est confronté à une page très
difficile de son histoire Israël soit
emmené par sans doute ce qui est je suis
désolé de lire mais un des pires premier
ministrre de son histoire merci François
gémen on va terminer cette émission par
le moment tant attendu direction le
Press Club de Paris vous nous attendez
Brigitte boucher Brigitte vous nous
révélez ce soir vous êtes membre du jury
hein bien sûr du prè de l'humour
politique vous nous révélez donc ce soir
le nom des différents gagnants c'est à
VOUS bonsoir mirriam je suis évidemment
en mesure de vous annoncer le Grand Prix
Press Club humour et politique de
l'année 2023 il a été décerné à l'ancien
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe pour
cette petite phrase si vous pensez qu'il
faut être un playboy en France pour être
élu j'ai quand même quelques
contre-exemples alors évidemment on l'a
interrogé sur les contreexemple mais il
n'a rien dit on ne sait pas s'il
s'adressait par exemple au prédécesseur
direct d'Emmanuel Macron en tout cas
Édouard Philippe confirme qu'il a de
l'humour puisqu'on lui avait déjà
décerné l'année dernière le prix spécial
du jury je vous propose écouter sa
réaction tout à l'heure de toutes les
formes d'humour
envisageable dans le monde politique
l'ironie
euh la
méchanceté la litote enfin bref de
toutes les
formes d'humour envisageable
l'autodérision est probablement la moins
dangereuse et
l'autodérision c'est aussi savoir
sourire de choses qui vous arrive et qui
ne sont pas
drôles d'autres prix ont également été
décernés comme le prix de la Révélation
attribué cette année à l'écologiste Éric
Piol pour cette phrase on connaissait le
puit du Fou maintenant on a le fou du
puit une petite pique vous l'aurez
compris adressée à Laurent viquier
Xavier Bertrand a également été
distingué il a remporté le prix de
l'autodérision pour avoir dit le
gouvernement de Madame bornne est aussi
expert en justice que moi moi je suis
expert en régime àaincissant parmi les
laoréas on retrouve également l'ancien
Premier ministre François Fillon le
communiste Fabien Roussel marlè Chiapa
ou encore la députée Sandrine Rousseau
voilà donc pour la moisson de l'année
2023 et on se retrouve bien sûr avec LCP
pour l'année prochaine le prix Press
Club humour et politique 2024 et merci
beaucoup Brigitte boucher bravo à
Édouard Philippe on verra ce que ça
donne si çaage l' sememblé quand même
beaucoup plus sympathique que celui de
ses abvectives des protections c'est
vrai en Belgique vous avez un beau
palmarès aussi en matière Duque oui je
suis pas sûron n pas une céréonie de
prix comme ça chaque année Merci à VOUS
François gémen merci les affranchis
Isabelle lasser Stéphanie despierr
revenez quand vous voulez pour nous
décrypter l'accord ou le non accord de
cette COP 28 c'est la fin de cette
émission pour la voir ou la revoir il y
a la chaîne Youtube d'elcp très belle
soirée documentaire Jean-Pierre gracien
à
demain
[Musique]